Speaker 1: I'm going to tell you today how
the rich and powerful really control American
politics. And it's so funny because it sounds like
a conspiracy headline. The truth about the elites
controlling our political system. But that's the
joke. That's what's funny about it. For all of
the people looking for the conspiracies for how
American politics is controlled, oh, it's a cabal
of pedophiles who trade kids and drink the blood
of children in exchange for favors, maybe outside
a pizza shop, I don't know. Or it's an elite
of Jewish men, maybe with space lasers or the
voting machine people. It's out in the open. It's
a conspiracy out in the open. The real way that
the rich and powerful control American politics
is publicly known. And we're going to go over
it here. You don't need to look for the hidden
conspiracy. Let's start with campaign financing.
The cost of running for office national office
in the US is huge and it continues going up,
which means candidates rely on donations from
corporations and wealthy people in order to
fund their campaigns. On average, the candidate
that raises more money wins and the donors expect
something in return for their investment. It's
out in the open. It's legalized bribery when a
candidate takes money from a donor. The donor on
average has influence over the candidate. Doesn't
mean they're meeting in person and saying,
here's what I need you to do. But it exerts
some influence for sure. And they can expect,
at least for the candidate to listen to them,
to take their concerns into account when making
policy decisions. And we find it in the facts.
We find there's that famous Princeton study from a
few years ago which found the legislative desires
of the wealthy and of corporations are much more
likely to be pursued as legislation and made into
law by our elected officials than the concerns
of just the average person. So it works. It's
out in the open. You don't need to search for the
secret way in which influence is being wielded.
It's not just politicians influenced by money. The
policymaking process itself is heavily influenced
by special interests and lobbyists, which then can
come in and say, Focus on this rather than that.
These are people who are paid. It's all legal to
advocate for certain policies on behalf of their
clients. They often have access to lawmakers that
you and I don't. They can make their voices heard
in ways that average people can't. And so it's
another part of the feedback loop that leads to
policies that may not be in the public interest,
but they benefit the select few that are using
their money to get that influence. But that's
money. There's more than just money that gives the
rich and powerful control over American politics.
They also have access to the best strategists who
can help them shape public opinion. Focus group
polling. Market research. And they can use those
strategists to influence the outcome of elections.
You and I don't have that. We can phone bank, we
can donate paltry sums, but we don't have access
to that. The political strategists are experts at
crafting messages, framing issues in ways that
are favorable to their clients and to theirs,
their desires. They've got the data, the market
research to understand what will work on voters,
and that's another reason they are more likely
to succeed. And then the third prong of this
is media and access to the media. Media can be
used in and of itself to shape public opinion and
to influence the political discourse, to include
certain topics and exclude others. And of course,
the money is used in order to influence media. And
media plays a major role in American politics. We
shouldn't. We should accurately assess what the
media is and isn't. But we have no choice if
we're connected to reality, to acknowledge that
media generates or wields the power to decide
what stories get covered in which stories don't,
how are they presented? What's the framing? Can
something be inserted or excluded from the public
discourse, which has a dramatic impact on both
elections and also on legislation passing or not?
When it comes to the wealthy and the powerful,
they often get favorable coverage either through
their use of strategists and PR people, through
their use of advertising dollars. And this can
make it really a difficult thing, an uphill battle
for just the average person to have their voice
heard in the same way. So it's all in the open.
Whenever you hear a conspiracy theory about the
secret campaign to wield influence and the elites
control, you could say the white. It's it's all
happening in the open. There's no need to find the
secret way in which it's being done now to counter
that influence. What can be done? Everybody has to
be voting as a starting point. Don't throw away
the one vote you have. We should be educated and
aware of the ways in which this is taking place.
Please, if you don't even know the mechanisms,
it's going to be hard to fight against them and
then support candidates and policies that are
number one in the public interest. But number
two would work to maybe defuze or reduce this
disproportionate power that the rich, wealthy
and corporations have. That's the way it is.
You don't need to find some secret conspiracy
because it's all happening out in the open